Ohm J. Gore
OHM: This is Ohm Gore from the United States,
a global change maker here on behalf of the
British Counsel. I am confident that global
growth will be restored in 2009 because growth
and effective economic performance is a measure
of confidence. With old leaders and old ideas,
we didn't have much confidence; well we did,
but now we lost it. We have, in my country,
in the United States, we have a new administration.
An administration that's ready to fund infrastructure
projects, pump cash into the econonmy, but
also have regulations that both insure that
executives are not able to swindle markets
as they have in the past, but also insure
that the American people, in fact the citizens
of the world, feel more confident about what
their govenment is doing, what's going on
on Wall Street and in their local economies.